most hookers are going to end up ghosts
they get brutally murdered so doesn't
every hooker kind of become a ghost if
that's the rule if they were servicing a
drama they didn't get to finish that's
unfinished business if they didn't
complete their job is that that's
probably why they're still on Earth
[Music]
a Texas homeowner says that makes a
claim that hooker ghosts have taken over
her rental property she's probably right
what happens God dang hooker ghosts yeah
you don't know Steve when you're a
person that has experienced ghosts when
you hear this claim how accurate do you
think she is I think it's 100 accurate
yeah because you believe all people
would go but do you think hooker ghosts
are like wanna have a good time and
they're still trying to hook while
you're like I do think that really
they're probably all dressed up like a
you know so you don't have to work the
streets no more you're a ghost this
woman her name's Linda Hilt she's the
owner of Hill House Manor by the way
does that sound haunted to you guys it
sure does it also sounds like a brothel
Hill House Manor Hill House Manor sounds
like a brothel anything with the manor
yeah for real what about Wayne Banner
Wayne Manor sounds like a brothel yeah
oh yeah it sounds haunted too this just
sounds like a husband's stretched lie
that went way too far and she's
believing him and she's like oh he said
it was hooker ghosts it wasn't hooker
well let me tell you what happened
listen my husband's not cheating on me
he's just [__] ghosts all day yeah
no they want to [__] him okay so this
one this woman her name's Linda Hill she
is taking a shower and all of a sudden
she hears someone say
looking good
oh
I thought she's like she's like I
thought it was my husband looking good
he and I are the only ones in the house
is that cool are you sure it's not a
taco boy
oh [__] that's not a hooker that's a
John
hahaha
she hears she's yeah I'm a hook I'm a
hooker ghost
yeah that too no so she goes identified
himself
she um she says you know she got she was
scared but then she's like oh thank you
and then she asked him what he'd been
doing that day and they had a
conversation and then he left
okay behind the curtain or what it was
like while she's in the shower behind
the shower curtain yeah yeah she had a
conversation she didn't open and be like
who [__] is there she didn't it wasn't
her husband so she just was like oh let
me just have a conversation with
somebody
yeah at Hill House Manor and at what
point does she decide it's a hooker and
not and not a John well they claim she
claims that they have already been
experiencing these hooker ghosts and she
actually and no because she says you
better not be making a hooker party I'm
not making enough that's the best part
of this whole [__] article I'm going
to try to make this article work around
that
she she she says in this interview she
says we've got kids she says we we have
different types of ghosts we have kids
we've got old people old guys and we've
got hookers of course of course yeah you
can see it right here it says that right
correct it does no it doesn't say that
so one one time it was a family house
another time it was just old people and
it was just like a brothel at one time
you don't know you never know you buy a
house you don't know what happened
before you ever thought you ever think
about all the generations that lived
before you in that house and in the
lives that they had yeah hookers that
lived in our house before us I think
about that because sometimes I go
did they argue a lot in this house like
and are the arguments stuck in the wall
isn't it like okay correct me if I'm
wrong but with ghosts that like stick
around is it like that uh Telltale old
age thing about
um they have unfinished business so they
stay in uh the Mortal realm type [__]
you know what I mean figure out whoever
that's the best selling argument yeah
well that means that whoever lived in
Hillhouse Manor Back The Day He was like
ordering some hookers I mean they
[__] killed him which is why they're
stuck there right but why are the
hookers so nice like my whole thing is
like so they're complimenting her they
say that as they rent this place out
male renters
[Music]
um have also told her that they felt
someone like stroking their face in the
night stroking their arm they're still
working in their afterlife yeah yeah
why are they complaining about it sounds
nice
I wouldn't mind living in a house with
hooker ghosts yeah someone struck my
hair every once in a while that's nice
you might wake up to a [__] or
something maybe not that much but like
you know you wake up being robbed and
then you're just like wait where's my
wallet hooker ghost floating around in
front of your face where's my [__]
hooker goes slow dude remember in
Ghostbusters when uh
remember when Dan aykwood is getting his
belt undone by Ghost and the ghost goes
down when I was a kid I didn't know what
the [__] was going on yeah let me get
right and then
yeah we get it now that though he was
getting a [__] but he says that that
was based on a real thing that happened
to him in real life he got a [__]
from a ghost Dan Aykroyd God can you
imagine actually admitting that if that
feels like anything what
I know because it's like you're getting
sucked by air yeah but think about it
visually once you like bust a nut and
then you just see the ghosts swallow
your semen but it's just like traveling
into like organs and then you see the
intestines and stuff like that too but I
don't know how it goes feel those are
gross dude I don't either he and nobody
and of course the host I think he was
good or Joe Rogan or something but they
didn't ask him like how does it feel get
your dick sucked by a ghost I think Joe
Rogan needs to ask the questions that
people all want to know I know but Joe
really just wanted to talk about DMT
more
Lex Freedom would have been like he
would have been like
was it a pleasurable experience
dude that's a perfect life yeah he's
like were you in love love life laughter
life
a conversation with a hooker ghost
[Laughter]
that sounds like inside the actor Studio
it always is like that with his cold
opens his cold opens are like that I'm
like I'm like this guy this guy's
[__] intense bro I think most hookers
are ghosts right most hookers are going
to end up ghosts they get brutally
murdered so doesn't every hooker kind of
become a ghost if that's the rule if
that's the rule if they have unfinished
business if they were servicing a drama
they didn't get to finish that's
unfinished business I can't imagine most
hookers that spend their life as hookers
are gonna if they didn't complete
complete their job is that that's
probably why they're still on Earth
Purgatory am I right guys
I'm just looking for come every time and
so they're going like oh hi hi looking
good I'm trying to get they're trying to
go over to the other side that's why you
know the compliments really helped that
somebody didn't settle the check Colleen
have you ever seen a ghost in real life
only hooker ghost I wouldn't mind seeing
a ghost if they look good
yeah if they're hot right because in the
movies they always look ugly they're
always like all mangled and [__]
apparently nobody stacked ever died
nobody stacked ever died is that what
you want to tell me yeah but then if
they do they die they show up with their
injuries and [__]
isn't that stupid oh yeah they're like
pretty right here and then they turn
their face
because like if you're
a comeback and like take any form you
want like you they're you're a stupid
ghost like you're seriously so dumb
because like I would be whatever the
[__] I wanted to be I don't think you
get to come back as a god
yeah that'd be cool yeah change your
[__] Essence bro you gotta remember
when like from According to Ghost
Hunters and like Taps that's that's what
I get all my ghost information from
ghosts need to gather energy from
electronic devices so they can only
create so much energy dude so that's the
only thing we don't have a lot of
electronic devices laying around today's
age where you know the EMP meters bro
they're they're [__] they're not
they're not hey we already know all the
rules about goats and how they look is
determined by the person that can see
them at that moment that's not true bro
no yay dude that's messy dude you're
being messy do you guys know anybody
that can see ghosts at the casigos like
you mean like at will yeah like like
like the character in The Sixth Sense
people people that openly say like oh I
see spirits I immediately I immediately
dismissed hey I go yeah because it
doesn't seem like something you'd want
like if you really experience that it
doesn't seem like a flex yeah yeah
Hannah sees them all the time really
yeah she tells me she was like oh
there's one right there she Flex in or
she's just like no it's casual it's
she's just been seeing it all her life
is she like that guy doesn't even have a
head
she's like that one's got some Heavies
she got some pelosis on her yeah yeah
just all her life and I think it's like
certain family members too they see it
but then the way she explained the
phenomena she's like yeah there's no way
to really understand but in the way that
she's accepted it is she believes like
time is kind of stacked right so what
we're seeing is the residual of
different time that you might see other
people times [__] stuck yeah stack
like the ghosts aren't we also a giant
sphere propelling all throughout space
and geographically nothing should be in
the same spot
could be huh overtime that's true
explain that [__] and I only say that
because that's that's because we're
moving like this but going
why like if it's
each other why doesn't it go like this
and it goes like [__] all that I only
say that because that's that's the
disprovement of why time travel can't be
possible like Back to the Future because
I was obsessed and I was like why can't
that happen and people are like well
that's because if you did jump through
time you would just be in some other
point in space and Earth would be all
the way the [__] over there and I was
like whoa no but wait wouldn't earth
like come back
[Laughter]
come back if you go back in time doesn't
Earth come back so Earth is moving are
you telling me that if I go back in time
in your little scenario yeah the light
would be different like the the the the
way that the sun is hitting the Earth
would be different well your you'll be
stationary right so then the the Earth
keeps moving like that so you'll be here
when you reappear so there's the middle
of [__] space floating basically
that's why the worst movie you could
ever make in a motionless Flat Earth
coordinate yeah you would you could go
back in time and be here five weeks ago
but five weeks ago this wouldn't Earth
wouldn't be in this spot yeah yeah but
isn't that the idea of going back in
time though going back to where Earth
was five weeks ago yeah it goes where
but then that wouldn't be time traveling
that would also be space travel like
you've got no benefit yeah because if
there's the Sun and then the Earth it's
going this way depending on the time of
the year too so if you're time traveling
in that position and it's spring you're
over here you appear here I got it
travel in a spaceship then you're back
in time now you just rock it towards the
Earth boom easy money because that's how
you know I'm like all right I'm gonna
time travel right now back to five weeks
ago I'm gonna be 50 miles away from
Earth so I gotta plant this spaceship
there right now no you travel in a
spaceship dude that's your Uber back to
Earth yeah exactly that's that's what
Neil deGrasse Tyson I think said that
and which which means that if you're
seeing ghosts in the in a place that you
live and they lived there before that
that makes ghosts subject to the laws of
gravity in which that would be weird
right
all right so why come I saw a shadowman
yeah why come I saw a shadowman I
thought we determined that he went to a
hole and he just went down a ladder
afterwards
it was just the [__] bellhop Hannah
saw a shadow man at the Luxor
yeah I don't believe you why you saw the
shadow man
uh it's my story it's my thing they
happen at hotels a lot yeah man no so oh
so she was it the same thing where it
was the middle of the night like um
early morning kind of thing no it was
middle of the night and um she says they
were watching us [__] and then she was
just like I don't want to tell you
because like you know it's kind of weird
but it happens yeah okay do the ghosts
give like two thumbs up
[Laughter]
he has a straight jacket on
no like it's like it's the way you
explain it it's just a shadowy figure
and then you do a double take and then
they disappear yeah and then didn't you
say you remember oh splattered yeah
you're you're busting a nut out of it I
said I was a spider no I was spotted
upon he came on you ectoplasm not calm
don't say dude
as quoted by Steve he said yeah and
afterwards I I was covered in [__] on my
face and tits
but now he's educated it's ectopus he
was just drugged at the bar and a guy
busted a nut on him
but it was it was so much it couldn't
have been just one guy that's why it was
a ghost it was a traumatic experience
for me it was a [__] surprise you guys
should show some respect to Steve I'm
glad I got to open up in this room it's
always very nice
because you're gonna [__] [__] all
over the story so that reminds me of
when I talked about how a one-time uh a
guy like put his hands on me like while
I was asleep and then Bart's like did it
feel good
what's the story oh yeah the guy a guy
put hands on me while I was asleep one
time like like he like molested wait
there's a true thing yeah yeah put
Handsome when when you were a kid no I
was like I was like a full-grown man I
was like [__] 23 years old we're
talking about ghosts or a real person no
real person like a dude like a dude I
was at I was uh I was crashing it was
like me and my cousin and we had all
gone out with like this work buddy of
mine
um and then he put hands on me like in
the middle of the [__] early morn
and I was like yo what the [__] I'm like
so it didn't feel good so exactly that
that was like one of my when I you know
I wasn't like a regular on JK yeah but I
remember I remember saying that and part
was like did it feel good
yeah and like how fast can you heal
right dude the darkness ever it's the
best way to heal it really is laughter
is the best medicine that is like
Neosporin to the soul
[Music]